Wow.
Well,
well,
go to your mom's house,
own
Christina
all over my vagina.
I will
turn around and go
talk to me like,
you know
what,
we
don't want it going down.
My leg went
on board with drop box
securities on the way now.
No,
it's just a lading honor period saying,
fuck yeah,
you're kids don't know that.
Have you ever had a,
you were saying somebody kicked out that was from last week's episode later was
really losing her mind,
bleeding out of her vagina on the plane.
You ever seen someone lose their mind on the plane?
Hmm.
I,
I feel like the answer's yes,
but I can't recall.
I feel like I've seen it all on planes.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
You have you seen one?
Yeah,
I saw,
I've seen a couple people get accosted by the,
uh,
flight attendants and I've,
I've seen,
uh,
somebody,
um,
I've,
I've returned to the gate before I had someone thrown off the plane.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
I learned later,
uh,
I think I've told the story,
but,
um,
this was a lady on small,
like a regional flight and she,
I guess she kind of was short with the flight attendant,
uh,
right before we were going to take off.
And the flight attendant then told the pilot and I was like,
no.
So we went all the way back to the gate and as they were s getting her off the
plane is when she was a really flipping out.
Yeah.
Because when she learned that she wasn't going to make the flight,
yeah.
She lost her mind.
You know,
cause they had to police waiting for it and everything.
Yeah.
Wow.
Cause some flight attendants don't play it off.
I did one,
I was on a flight this year where,
so this is the weirdest thing I was in first of course,
like I'm not a piece of shit.
And a guy,
um,
was hanging out in the galley and I heard the flight attendant go,
I've told you to go back to your seat.
And the guy who was an older guy,
he was like,
I want to stand here.
I can't and he's like,
you can't stand here,
you have to go back.
And then somebody in first that he knew,
it was like the guy,
the older guy goes,
he said I could have his seat.
And he goes,
you can't.
why?
He goes,
because I said,
so you don't get to decide that hey got heated.
Then they had a pilot come out this,
this is already,
this is mid air though.
This is during the flight.
And the pilot was like,
you have to obey this guy.
You have to go to your seat.
And the guy kept hanging out.
Yeah.
It was against define it and I was like,
this mother fucker is going to cause us
Delania land.
Don't you think that's enough?
Like I,
I'm so I'm afraid of of that kind of authority.
Like when,
when there's no exit for you,
like you're on that plane bro.
You're,
you're under their mercy.
Like just follow the rules.
Dip Shit.
He was like,
my back hurts.
Don't,
don't take the flight.
Yeah.
He was like,
get the fuck back there.
But can you imagine like I,
you know,
I've talked to my fair share of shit on a flight attendant should want to talk
some shit but real talk,
that's gotta be a such a hard job.
I mean you're dealing with,
yeah,
of course.
The general public who can't seem to figure out simple shit,
like put a fucking bag under the seat in front of you or put it up there or can,
you know,
consolidate your goods,
things like that.
You know,
people are dumb as fuck.
One time I was boarding and I stopped to help a lady,
like an older lady put her bag up and a girl,
a woman behind me goes,
are you kidding me right now?
And I turned around help somebody cause I,
cause I was stopped.
Oh God.
I turned around and I go,
what?
And she was like,
I go,
I'm helping her put her back.
She's like,
all right,
but come on man.
This was like as as I'm boarding the flight.
Yeah.
I'd probably say something like that to somebody.
Really.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It is crazy.
It,
especially if it's like an early morning flight.
Sometimes I'm real grumpy and I might,
I might say things,
I don't know if I actually say them out loud,
but I say them in my head.
Yeah.
Does that count?
No,
no.
You can say all kinds of things.
I don't think I've actually said out loud,
but I've definitely thought it.
Yeah.
But then that's why I have so much respect and admiration for the period lady.
Cause like I've,
I've had thoughts like that,
but for someone to just say it,
I really respect that.
I really admire it.
The fact that it was like losing her mind.
Yeah.
Talking about bleeding out of her fat and everything and that level of
obsessiveness is like you're at the break.
Yeah.
And I've been there emotionally.
I just have never let the dam burst like that.
But yeah,
I feel like I,
you know,
I get it.
I respect a bit.
You can.
Good for you.
I respected the guy who was trying to cover his face and correct.
Yeah.
That's identified with that guy.
So it's like,
oh man.
And then his laughing too because he was cringing and then shaking.
Laughing.
Yeah.
I felt like I was,
that guy took good time that that one you have to see.
But that guy,
that guy is me.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Um,
should we play our or show open here?
Do this correctly.
Let's do it,
man.
Let's do it.
Well,
come beautiful beings.
We talked before this video is how to activate your lingam upon those who don't
know the word Lingam is relating to the genitals and male genital area.
And you know another way of putting it within this video would be how to
activate your cook power.
Oh was Randy.
Don't bring in one.
Love it.
Fucking scumbag.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina pushes.
It's increasing.
These guys are the same.
They're all the same.
That's where I get my favorite.
I mean you can always identify them by their stupid jewelry.
Yeah,
yeah.
The arm part of the front of the brand,
right?
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Don't you feel like that's the,
that's how you can identify a Douche bag like this.
It does.
He have a thumb rate and our man paint on his forehead.
Good damage.
Cause that other guy,
the Indian guy remember the,
uh,
the finger into girls at the same time and how to hug twin activation.
Yeah.
Got us to an activation.
This fucking guy.
Yeah,
he's got it.
He,
yeah,
he's got his third I highlighted.
Yeah.
And then it's always like the Robie necklace with some bullshit thing on it.
You know how to activate your cock power.
I have a few ways that I can activate mine.
I don't know if I need a lesson,
but let's see what we can learn from my guys.
Know that right.
Of course are year old knows that this is just a lane to get your cock into
someone else.
Yeah.
The whole idea here as men to realize that your genital area,
your lingo is a very sacred place.
We know that.
Why we all know that.
And then I,
you know,
do I have to point out the obvious critique here?
What is that?
It's a white guy talking like a Rastafarian dude,
please French.
Are you sure?
Definitely.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I heard Rosta I thought he was pretending to be like a Jamaican Bro.
Please.
I'm the master of fucking like I tell them this whole time,
I was like,
oh,
okay man.
I swear I hear that.
I,
I thought I heard Rosta he might be living there,
but he's definitely French.
Wow.
This dude's first language is French.
Yeah,
that makes sense now cause I was like this mother fucker pretend like he
Jamaican or some shit.
Motherfucker.
You went to makings man.
Um,
have a good relationship with your,
your lingo lead to becoming using is like the pleasure Jimmy.
Pleasure.
You know,
it's very demanding.
It's very rough in the approach.
Yeah.
And let me guess.
We should have someone else kind of take care of it for us.
What w what should we do with it?
I don't know,
but I wish he'd put his fucking arm down.
I can't stand that.
He's doing a video hanging one arm.
I was really strapped.
I don't want to see his fucking smelly armpit.
I want to see a stupid fucking gold band.
Dirty fucking frog.
But John Are Debbie.
Yeah.
And one of the core practices that you can bring into your life.
It's a practice of self love.
Touching yourself and activating your whole genital area through a self
nurturing massage.
Picnics.
I mean,
so far the distinction that's been made is that a lot of us are too rough with
our dicks and he's like,
you should be nicer to it and be nice and you're a dick.
That's the lesson so far.
Right.
And again,
I don't,
I don't think you need to teach men.
It seems pretty innate because our son who's a year old is ferociously attacking
his penis and that he didn't need us to tell him no.
That,
that sounds like a rough,
what's wrong with that?
What are the guy goes,
I don't like to do nice touches.
I like rough.
That's founded like the Super Gay,
like the,
uh,
what,
what about the,
the wham video though?
That's not a soft touch.
That's a very rough,
she power cleans him from the floor by the falls.
But do budget or bug,
that's the best
for those of you.
It's on our Twitter feeds or you have to search back a little ways.
No bits there and um,
yeah,
it,
it's out there guys.
It's on my Twitter feed.
How can I get my Lingam to be my friend?
And uh,
so this is very different than masturbation.
It's very different than wanting to go for ejaculation watching porn.
You know,
that's tough.
We're talking about giving your cock,
your Lingam love some real love.
That's all this fucking nonsense.
Those are all his,
uh,
lesson plans.
I think all of his,
uh,
ancient Sanskrit bullshit.
He has drawings all over the wall and all this,
you know,
when is this Kama Sutra?
Yeah.
Fuck swings.
And now what's your guests though?
Let's say I go,
okay,
this guy,
you meet this guy,
you're on the beach.
Yeah.
Do you think he knows how to show your good time?
At least this guy?
Yeah.
You know,
I have to tell you,
I'm sure he current load with a lot of women,
but personally,
this kind of sensitive energy stuff,
it repels.
It just repels me.
But you don't think this guy knows how to eat a box?
So I don't know,
man.
I think he's probably the,
I think it's too emotional for me.
I think he wants to maintain eye contact while he does it.
Oh,
definitely.
100% that would make me so uncomfortable.
And you're looking for more like of a sport.
Fuck right.
I'm not looking.
That's what you're looking for.
I'm looking for a dude.
I feel like this guy is not,
you want it more
masculine,
his feminine energy.
Not necessarily.
Not necessarily that.
Yeah,
I just think he's a little too central.
It's too much.
Too many feelings.
I can't,
I can't handle feelings.
You know that what you can't handle feeling like his two emo for me.
He's way to email you say that he's going to start crying,
which I feel like he would,
he would cry and want to hold me a lot.
Mm.
And we'd have to talk about our feelings afterwards.
Shit.
Yeah.
I don't want to cry after and hold each other.
All right.
So I'm saying I'm Karen.
You won't downtown and Trish.
I'm Karen.
Yeah.
So the way it works is very simple.
Just take some I such oils,
some coconut oil and start pouring it on your lingam and spend,
you know,
five,
10 minutes,
half an hour,
just nurturing this area.
Could you even do that for five or 10 minutes or half and he jumped the half an
hour with coconut oil.
What Nice touches.
How long do you think you would last massaging your Lingam for?
With the coconut oil wouldn't be five to 10
much faster
as I imagine most humans,
but he would tell me that's the problem.
You know,
always like,
give me pleasure.
Bye.
[inaudible].
Yeah,
that's true.
Soon as you start touching,
it's gone.
Listen to this star,
a more nurturing and more healing and more loving.
Then eventually what happens is that there is a massive expansion of this area
means that there is an energetic and emotional release that happens and shells
and your penis traumas there are being released and there is a,
an energetic expansion.
If that happens,
all I would say,
it's not so much like you would notice that as soon as you start touching this
area,
you will notice that there are movements that you can make.
There's more wacky jewelry that are going to be how much jewelry,
you know that's all going to come naturally.
Musical instrument and playing with it.
Same with your,
your balls with your testicles,
you know your testicle area.
The same with the Perry name,
which is between,
uh,
the bees.
Okay,
man,
sister,
I'm tapped out.
Your inner Lorea spent plenty of time down there and then there was all the anal
area as well that you can pay with that you can't really
base Chakra Area Chakra needs your love.
Yeah,
very smell.
Nice to do.
Just that,
you know,
to start cultivating our relationship with that.
Thank you.
She's nurturing and loving.
Again,
this isn't a very lucky because they already have the circles.
They already high and magical.
The way they cultivate a love for the Yoni.
They look at each other.
They work with mirrors about the anatomy stuff,
breast massage and all that stuff.
Guys who were a little bit behind.
Okay.
It's time to catch up.
Catch up the stack,
bringing those techniques right.
I have an idea,
Tom,
right?
You've got a neat group of guy friends do this with them.
Why don't you invite them over and have a a lingam appreciation night.
Get a bunch of coconut oil,
keeps it spent a good 30 minutes just massaging each other's balls.
Why each other's I think it's self love.
He was talking about,
oh sorry.
And then you can bring up the mirrors and just sit in a circle.
Right.
And uh,
I mean Burt would obviously be on board.
Yeah.
A sickler.
Do it.
Yeah,
he would do it.
definitely met full charge Matt.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Who else could do it?
The,
as Joey Diaz was really on board with,
what do you think he'd bring to the table?
Joe Probably wouldn't be on board.
I think it would be,
I think it would definitely bring in a new level of excitement to the situation.
Uh,
you think Joe would want to do that?
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
I was signed out.
The pleasure.
Yeah.
Power.
It reminds me of this guy reminds me of like the Gos at Club Med.
Yeah.
A club meds.
A French vacation spot and there's a good chance this guy was a g.
Yeah.
I think he may have.
The only leg that to Potty,
you'd see what the disco later.
Why don't you remind our audience that could tackle for those who are
unfamiliar,
what the,
uh,
Geo said to you,
oh,
I don't want to talk about really trying to forget it.
Well,
I mean you brought it up,
but I just figured,
you know,
yeah.
I don't want to talk.
I mean,
look,
I won't,
I won't.
When I was 28 with my dad,
that's the last time I went to Club Med and my dad's been taking me in Club Med
since I was like 11 party fun part,
the fun dancing,
dancing free page,
everything's included.
I don't have to fucking pay more,
you know,
the everything at the
bar,
I can get what I want all day long.
It's the best.
But for both,
I both rebel.
There is the best.
And so they are,
they're all French.
And um,
you know,
one of the GL is just hit on me grossly and was like,
you want to come back to my room?
I have a bottle of lube and a mirror.
That's a real aggressive,
uh,
line,
you think?
Well,
yeah.
Who takes him?
They can't be the first time he said that.
I mean,
was he soft?
So say something like,
here's the odd part.
Is that this dude I was,
I was at breakfast and I was alone and I was working on jokes at the time.
I was just writing jokes.
Yeah.
Fucking sit sitting by myself with a plate of fruit and he sits down next to me
cause the gos are encouraged to socialize with the guests.
Yeah.
And they CICI with strangers at every meal,
which is horrible.
Horrible.
But it's French.
It's European.
They are,
the whole thing is that you should socialize and meet new people.
So I was sitting alone,
which in Club Med world is considered bad and he sits down next to me and I
forgot I didn't,
we were talking about the most banal things,
you know,
like,
Oh,
you're with your dad angry.
Thinking about cruise ships.
Those are even worse.
No,
I'm saying cause it's the same arrangement,
right?
Oh,
when they seat you with people.
Ah,
is there anything worse than that?
I hated to fucking hate because it's energy to speak to strangers.
What do you do?
What do you do with,
where are you from?
Where are you from with family?
My siblings always.
The first thing we do is try to locate the dining room manager and say something
like,
we're,
we can't sit with another group.
And then like,
and then sometimes you have to like really push to make it happen.
Well,
you're there with your family,
which implies to sit with a stranger.
Why would you want to talk to anybody else?
And again,
it's just small talk,
which I deplore small talk I don't want,
I don't want you to know where I live.
How about that?
Yeah.
Terrible.
How about it?
I don't tell you what I do for a fucking living.
I don't want to talk about my job when I'm on vacation.
It's terrible.
Terrible.
It's just float.
Yeah.
I like everybody.
Shut the fuck up and have all I talked to you.
I want to like,
if I don't,
you know,
I don't know.
It's forced to right away too.
Yeah.
He'd meet people.
You're like,
I don't want to have dinner with this person knows what they're having.
You do know,
have dinner with them.
I don't want to have a meal,
which is sacred.
I mean,
you break bread with your family,
with your friends.
No fucking strangers.
Some douchebag.
Fucking Dad boner.
Where?
From Shreveport?
Where are you from?
Ah,
fuck.
And La,
Huh?
Yeah.
Earthquakes,
you know?
Yeah.
And then they go,
they're always like,
ah,
no,
we're from Cleveland.
And you're like,
okay.
And they're like,
hey,
de la.
Right.
Cool.
Everybody hates La.
And again,
thank you.
Everybody hates La,
except for the people who live in now.
I know.
That's the only that they feel the need to tell you.
I don't want,
no one goes like you don't go,
Oh,
you from Cleveland.
I fucking hate that place.
I don't know.
That would be rude.
I live in La that I hate that place,
you know?
All right,
cool man.
I swear it's my home.
It's one of the few
cities where everybody can just openly say that and there's very little
pushback.
Yeah.
Well,
we do have a lot of Douche bags.
I mean in,
in those people's different like show business,
there's nothing do shear it then show business.
But it's also not just no massive city.
I know,
but most people don't know that there's like regular,
they'd be like,
oh,
people always like all these like small town fucking dorks that you meet that
say stuff.
Like they'll go,
I'm not into Hollywood.
And you're like,
what do you mean how they would be like,
ah,
showbiz and the red carpet.
And you're like,
do you think that's everywhere?
You didn't want to go out to dinner at the red carpet event.
This is the restaurant man.
Yeah.
That's a very small section of this business I guess too.
There's,
you know,
I'm not in the movie stars,
but people tell me that all the time.
And I'm like,
okay,
do you think it'll be hard to avoid them?
Well,
and also it's just a business when you think about it,
you know,
it's just,
uh,
Kate Hudson,
I'm sure there's night she doesn't want to put on a dress and go to some boring
ass award show.
Yeah.
For hours and hours and you know,
put the makeup on and all that fucking shit to business.
Yeah.
It is selling a fantasy guys.
That's all it is,
men.
Um,
so I guess we should,
we should get our Cox ready,
but also,
um,
we should tell people if they don't already know what happened
last year.
A cut Brian not mean God,
right?
I mean,
you're a cunt Brian,
not me.
Yeah,
yeah.
Is the man
we uh,
we gave it to you.
We brought them into your world.
Yeah.
And then we had them in our world and have lunch with him.
We had lunch with the Great Dan Pena.
Can you believe it?
I mean,
like you said,
when,
when you met the guy,
the bikes kid.
Yeah.
You were like,
this is amazing.
Ex Girlfriend,
Dick's girlfriend,
right over the bikes kid.
I mean,
this is just the magic of the Internet that we see this guy's video.
You knew I would immediately be fascinated and drawn to and love with Dan Pena.
Yeah.
And then I kept it,
we,
I,
we had,
he came on the show with a Skype interview.
Skype from Scotland,
right.
Scotland,
sorry.
We're England,
Scotland,
Scotland.
Yup.
And then,
um,
I kept,
we kept in touch via direct message and he said he's going to come out here in
March and then,
you know,
we made an appointment,
we had lunch with Dan Pena.
That's crazy.
And this is why you're fucking crazy.
The best part is that you and I dressed up.
Well that was part of our thing was like,
I mean we thought about it and I go,
I got to do it.
Um,
you know,
we wear t shirt and jeans every day.
Course omics.
What else is there for meetings and for everything.
It's just,
that's how it is out here.
And it was like,
here,
this will be fun.
Why don't we surprise him by dressing for the occasion?
Cause I knew he,
I know he has a big thing about,
you know,
jeans and a dress like a fucking bum.
So it was like,
let's,
let's do it up.
Here's what happened though.
I first,
I bought a suit over the summer and a nice suit.
I put it on and it was like,
it was like a little boy putting on daddy suit.
It's from the weight loss.
Yeah.
I couldn't even cinch it with a belt.
How many looks,
I assert,
how many sizes did you go down?
Um,
at least two full suit sizes.
So it made it,
it looked comically ridiculous.
So I was like,
fuck.
I think it was kind of throwing my whole,
you know,
idea into to shit.
Right.
So I found another suit.
It was also oversized,
but I go,
uh,
it won't look as bad.
I don't know.
I just put a belt on.
I tightened it,
put the jacket on.
Here's the thing,
you can back me up on this because you've heard me say this many times.
It's one of my pet peeves is when I watch TV and there's a,
you know,
a guy especially of means,
a coach athlete.
Trump.
Yeah.
And they're wearing a poor fitting suit.
My God,
it kills me.
It makes me crazy.
Donald Trump,
where's his fucking frumpy dump?
He wears,
he wears expensive suits that don't flatter his body type.
It's terrible.
That's what,
that's,
that's the,
because he is of the mentality that,
that if it's expensive then it's great.
But the fabrics that he wears don't,
don't do anything for him.
He should be wearing thicker.
He was wearing like Charlotte lighter,
more luxurious fabrics and he should be wearing like thicker wool and the
tailoring doesn't look,
tailoring doesn't look like I know some tail.
And I tell you,
it bothered me so much when I was looking in the mirror and I was getting ready
to do,
even when we got to the hotel and I was like,
I can't ever,
I hated the way it sat on the shoulders,
uh,
past the risks.
It looked so goofy.
Daddy.
I did.
I felt it was wearing daddy's suit like a little boy.
We're in daddy suit.
It bothered me so much here.
I'm definitely going to go get another suit.
Um,
well we went across the street after lunch and we picked one.
No looked at them at,
but I also had to give the people that I bought the suit to back and he was
like,
this is going to take days because we have to basically recut the,
the jacket and the pants because you've lost.
It's like,
it's not just a modification.
We have to recut and Riso this thing.
Oh.
So I dunno,
I'm definitely getting another suit,
uh,
one that fits me like,
you know,
for my size,
but it made me crazy.
That's just all I want to say.
It made me crazy and it still makes me crazy when I see it in other people.
And you go,
why wouldn't you just have the Taylor bring that in half an inch here?
Why wouldn't you have them bring the,
you know,
the waistline in just a bit.
Just it costs you,
it costs nothing.
Nothing.
Now it's really upsetting to me is my art teacher jacket,
which by the way,
we've offended many an art teacher.
I
know that my best friend is an art teacher.
She was very upset.
Yeah.
I had that jacket altered.
I,
it was just an h and m jacket.
But at the time I was real fat after giving birth and I want it to look nice
even if I was fat and I was upset because I feel like I made an effort with that
jacket.
And you still were like,
no,
I know it's hideous.
So I tried,
you know,
I tried the art teacher jacket had to go.
I did.
It's gone.
I know I gave it away.
Our Nannies sister has it now.
You really gave it away.
I did.
Well it's my husband.
If you tell me you don't like it,
why would I work with me that you hate?
Wow.
Then you have to look at me and you hate how I look.
You're the only person who really looks at me,
you know?
You know what I mean?
On a daily basis.
You're the,
you're the one whose opinion matters.
I don't fucking look at myself.
Um,
so damn pain yet.
What was it like?
I,
I texted some friends,
family and they were like,
oh,
is he an asshole?
And it's funny cause I don't think of him as an asshole at all.
The affection that I have for him is directly tied to youth football.
Oh,
I,
I was drawn to coaches that were like,
that.
The people misinterpret the yelling,
he's an asshole.
He's mean for me.
It was trying to get the most out of you.
And a lot of times,
I mean,
my favorite coaches ever were guys like that.
And then they would always,
you know,
they're the guys that you'd,
you'd die for anything.
For those guys,
I always say beware of the,
the bullshit or the one who pretends to be nice all the time.
The people who pretend to be perfect and not curse and be holier than that.
Those are generally the ones you should watch out for.
Yeah.
It's not the guy that's looking to tell you what's up,
you know?
Yeah.
But we had a delightful lunch with Pena and um,
you know,
we really,
I mean,
we just kind of shot the shit caught up.
He was,
he was extremely gracious and ask questions about,
you know,
what we're doing.
He asked questions about our business,
how things like,
you know,
how touring works and all that and seemed interested in that.
And um,
it was just,
it was a,
it was a nice time talking about family,
his family,
our family life,
a little bit what he likes to do.
And you know,
he,
he's been speaking a lot at schools.
He says torn speaking and doing a lot of and also a bunch of charity stuff,
charity stuff,
orphanages and stuff.
Uh,
well really pleasant,
pleasant lunch.
Yeah,
it was fun.
Yeah.
And then he did Joe show too.
He did.
Um,
yeah.
Got In touch with Rogan.
He did Rogan's podcast.
Uh,
I got,
I got caught a little bit of that.
I was on the road and I remembered that they were doing it Friday.
So I was at the gym in the hotel and I,
I pulled up the live feed and I was watching he wear his Tux.
He was wearing like,
kind of like what we wore to lunch.
Yeah.
With the bow tie.
And his outlet for lunch was a,
it was a vest that was like,
what was the word for
that?
What kind of vest is at,
it looks like a tapestry.
Kind of like when they do on colorful.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
And then like a coat.
Right.
And then Nice slacks.
And then he had on these great slipper,
they were like leisure ridiculous Versace kind of slippery,
which is so cute.
It was great.
You know,
and the swag to pull it off.
Massive swag.
Yeah.
So I guess he's visiting La for a minute and then he's going to go back to his
castle and teach a seminar.
Yeah.
Doing,
doing some traveling and uh,
yeah,
teaching the seminar.
He only does a few of those a year.
It's not like a year round thing,
you know,
I get the emails,
the Qla seminar.
Yeah.
That's an intense thing.
I,
part of me feels like I would do that to have like for the experience if I had
the time.
Yeah.
But it's really intensive too.
I mean,
apparently to go into that you fill out hundreds of questions and,
yeah,
yeah.
So you get,
because it's a limited class size is like no more than 16 or something 20 maybe.
Um,
and sometimes smaller and so he knows you really,
really well.
But I dunno,
I just feel like it'd be something I would enjoy it.
But you have to wear a suit every day to class.
Be Fun to go shopping first
jeans,
you bum fucking fucking losers.
Really crazy hours.
He was saying they start at 8:00 AM and they don't go to bed till midnight.
Yeah.
This is why your fucking do you even push that?
No,
I think my arm kind of bumbled.
Yeah,
that was the sole dad.
He was telling me that I don't want to get up early and go to bed late and then
he goes,
this is why you're fucking poor.
You just lectured me.
Yeah.
Now he's so strong and he had all kinds of knee surgeries and yeah.
Big Guy.
Too Big frame.
Taller than I thought.
Yeah.
Taller and his skin looked amazing.
I got to say he his face,
no wrinkles.
No,
no.
I was like,
Damn,
champaign you notice thing and stuff like that.
What's going on you that Unicorn blood.
There's a thing though.
People should know.
I mean,
you should know this too.
If you're a big guy.
Um,
oversized clothing in general,
not just suits is worse looking then too tight,
not too tight.
I mean
big like way too big for you.
If you're a big guy,
you might be like,
I'm going to buy a shirt two times bigger than my size.
You look terrible.
Terrible.
It looks like a dress.
It actually highlights your fat.
Yeah,
it looks terrible on television.
When you're on television,
you should be tailored to fit you.
Not too tight so that your titties show.
But people message me all the time that,
uh,
after we said that you should,
you know,
it's real easy to get jeans tegular just a little bit and they love it.
Easiest thing to do when you buy jeans,
it doesn't matter.
You go get a pair of Levi's or whatever,
then you go to a dry cleaner,
um,
or just whatever Taylor and you just have them make little,
you know,
maybe the hem a little bit up.
Maybe you need the waste adjusted slightly.
Just so that it fits you well.
They look totally different,
you know,
cause back in the olden days,
uh,
that you,
you couldn't buy ready made clothing.
Everything was made for you.
It's super expensive.
So now everything's off the factory.
But if you can just do,
like you said,
little fucking little modifications,
then you're going to look tight.
You are,
you're going to look good.
Hi In fucking tight man.
Um,
yeah.
So,
uh,
I went out of town,
I went to Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania and Jesus was born Masha and tech.
It been there.
Foxwoods,
the Fox theater.
It was,
the weather was cray cray.
I was getting real cold and then I did Boston mazing time in Boston.
I say always is fucking incredible.
I like all those places you named.
Actually Boston is the shit.
And uh,
the Wilbur,
it's just like,
it's a magical place for standup.
I don't know what it is.
Like it's a smart city.
Yeah.
Savvy,
savvy,
fun.
The crowds are awesome.
I had a great time.
Great time.
Um,
so thanks to everybody that,
that came out to the shows.
Um,
I was,
uh,
here with Lj this weekend.
We went to the country club and I made a little,
yeah.
Why don't we,
uh,
yeah.
If you've,
I've never heard you this excited ever about anything.
Jean got herself a high watch and uh,
you would really think you'd think she'd been in a cave for the last 25 years
and she wasn't aware of a,
I don't know any smart technology because I've never heard you like,
you're like,
I'm texting you from my watch.
I'm,
I'm tall.
I'm calling you from my watch or something.
I'm checking the weather from my watch.
Oh,
excited.
Here's why.
When I was a little girl and you dream about the year 2000,
we were promised these fucking 17 years ago.
They know.
It's funny thing is that they've been out for a while now.
How long the Iwatch,
I mean,
at least at least a few years.
Well,
look,
I grew up watching inspector gadget and I always am like James Bond Shit.
And I always used to love and gadget would,
you could take fucking phone calls,
but how did you miss it the last few years?
I just,
you know what it is is that I don't wear a watch is generally true.
And so I was like,
man,
I don't give a fuck.
You know,
what am I missing out on?
That's why I thought you when you were,
when we started showing interest,
so I was like you're definitely not going to wear no cause I watch my swatches
and I'm like my wife for like a week and then I forget you still
well occasionally put one on and you'll wear it.
You know for a minute
you don't regularly do it.
But here's why my life changed is that with baby jeans.
Okay,
here's what I do.
Cause when I go out alone with him,
when you're out of town,
it Jean baby jeans and I go to the country club,
right?
I have to take the fucking diaper bag,
which means I can't carry a purse.
So I got my fanny pack now I got the fanny pack and then I got the phone.
And they've got the baby.
I got the store,
I got the shit,
and every time you're texting me or let's say something,
you know,
I don't want to dig for my phone every two seconds.
It's so irritating.
I'm constantly looking for my phone.
So this way it's on my route and every text that comes in and they can call you
like you called us and I was on the road with a baby jeans and I just want to
boot like this.
I was driving like this and then I went,
whew.
Hi Gina and I could fucking talk to you.
And I didn't have to look for my phone.
Wow.
I mean,
I just like anything that prevents me from having to obsess about where,
where's the phone?
What am I gonna you know?
It's just one less thing in my life to fucking do it.
To see you this excited.
Honestly.
You mean you like my joy?
I don't think so.
I think you like it when I'm miserable.
Why would I like it when you're miserable?
Just kidding.
I don't know why I'm in love with it now.
Apple store can go fuck itself.
Every time I've ever stepped foot in there.
It is an absolute misery,
God forbid if something should break and you should want it fixed.
Cause that's another fucking quagmire.
Inefficiency shot.
Did fix the uh,
the computer,
the Puente or hear the sound drop one?
Yeah,
they fixed it.
And then I realized that I had an older one that has an issue,
not the same issue.
What kind of an issue like that?
So when I pick this one up,
I go,
can you look at this one?
You gotta make an appointment,
do right here.
He's like,
so I know just to help me help please.
You know,
as a store where you walk in somewhere and they have to go like,
what do you need?
And then you're like,
I want to talk to someone about this.
Go wait at that table.
It's the coolest product and it's the absolute worst customer service.
I fucking walked in there at baby jeans.
And if you have a toddler,
you know that you have exactly 20 minutes to do anything before that kid has a
meltdown.
Those were the rules.
So I've rolled them in there and I go,
look man,
I got 20 minutes.
I'm alone with this toddler.
Get me my watch.
I know what I want.
I picked it out in advance.
I stood there,
nobody was helping me and I'm begging,
I go,
can I please give you $400 I have,
I have the money.
Here's my,
can someone take money and put you on the list?
I said,
mother Fucker,
that was 10 minutes ago.
Help me,
help me.
Oh,
I've gone busy and they're not,
they're fucking doodling on their thing.
Oh my God.
I could've just,
I live almost blew a gasket.
And then finally they help you.
And then do you judge or Una just,
um,
when you're in the apple store and they have an older employee,
never,
I will never got an older employee.
Never.
I'll take dreads.
Thank horse.
Of course I'll take the non binary with person with braces.
It's like this fifth grader I talked to you GRANDPA card.
They don't know what they're doing.
No,
I want a millennial and looking at a maximum.
Yeah.
I think give me a millennial.
And then the worst part is they go,
do you want to activate the watch now?
I go,
of course,
what am I going?
What do you mean when I'm going to come back?
So then of course I go to the go over here,
there's again 10 people like you said,
and then one fucking employee helping all US old fogies activate.
So every 10 seconds when you know,
then she has to come back when she fucking can.
Yeah.
And then he's of course he melted down.
He started screaming and crying in the middle of the store.
Everybody stopped.
They were doing and stared is terrible.
I had to give them goldfish and you know,
put them in my lab.
It was terrible.
It's the worst source man.
But the products are so cool.
I just keeps me coming back from war,
like an abusive boyfriend and they're so mean to you or a drug there.
Terror.
And also you start getting tied into your products being tied to each other.
Of course,
that's the real rack because you might go,
oh,
I want to,
I'm on an Android,
I want a different phone.
But then you start to think,
well you can,
but you start to think,
will this be a headache and do I want to deal with that?
That's the problem.
And I know in the day I want to break free.
I want to try other things.
You know he do.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
I thought you were an apple loyalist.
No,
no,
they've,
I've just have products.
I'm like,
I said,
they're tied together.
So I go,
Oh God,
it's easier.
Easy.
He is convenience.
But that doesn't mean I don't want to try like an Android,
you know?
Yeah.
So I want to try it.
You know what I miss is a blackberry.
I know.
And I love it with the,
I like the pushy button.
Me Too.
We'll keyboard.
I'm so sick of everything.
I type,
it never comes out accurately.
It's every,
everything is changing.
And it's youth.
You had girls night out too.
Well,
by Stan.
I did.
I had dinner with girl,
have girlfriends.
And how was that a good cause I never have fun.
I'm
really,
you're recorded as talking to you.
Yeah.
You know what I think?
Why can't shit.
Why?
Because of that dinner,
I had pasta and meat and cheese and I didn't.
Now I haven't had enough veggie since.
Yeah.
I,
that's why I'm not shitting.
God dammit.
You haven't had enough Veggie you think?
Yeah,
that's,
it's a fiber.
So I had two bowls of soup soup and a mango and some coffee.
I'm hoping that that will drum up some,
some fours and fives.
That dog barking bit was so funny that I feel like I have to
muscle Myosin myofilaments lie side by side and the apes stones and I pan Aryton
maximum width during contraction.
The Actin and Myocin myofilaments interact.
You bored or almost each myocin myo filament.
Yeah.
I like your honesty with that.
That was interesting.
And a,
yeah.
Doesn't take very long.
Yeah.
Um,
we should do this while,
uh,
once again,
Ra's dude,
blood dones the instrumental,
um,
a lot more topics.
Gene,
we got a lot more to cover.
We're doing our instrument.
We're doing our live tapes.
I know Ben too.
We got a lot of even scratch that.
We're fucking done.
A,
I'm going to be in Green Bay.
Uh,
Wisconsin Jean Jean's.
Hey Jean Gay gene gaugings Wisconsin.
A one show this Thursday.
Come out if you're in Wisconsin,
a Friday at the Trois Royal Oak.
I'm doing that.
And then Saturday and Sunday chicargo the Vic,
there are still some tickets left if you live in Chicago,
Chicago,
Illinois for the Sunday later show.
Um,
then after that I'm going to a bunch of places.
Burlington,
Vermont,
Pittsburgh,
um,
new haven,
Connecticut,
Connecticut.
I have Washington,
Washington,
Dick Com.
Those are all short sold out.
Um,
I added a show in Portland,
Portland,
Oregon.
May 13th,
Eugene,
Oregon,
May 12th,
uh,
meet rattled Washington and Seattle is a,
it has been added as well.
I added a late show there April 14th,
so if you can get tickets to that shit dog and a dog.
Oh,
next week.
Next week.
I have a big announcement.
It's already,
it's already signed.
You know about it already,
but I can't announce yet.
I did,
yeah.
Okay.
Where I told you I was going remember?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Very good.
That'll be fine.
Yeah,
go ahead gene.
Um,
April 13th through 15th.
I'm at the Bray and profit.
Now.
What would bratby fuck?
There's nothing for Braya Dyer.
Brad.
There you go.
Genius.
April 28th or 29th,
uh,
sack twisting.
Mental.
Yeah,
the punchline.
Great Club.
Great Clap.
May 4th through fifth fart.
Next Arizona at up live.
Yeah.
May 19th or 20th June dork.
Teddy's at Gotham comedy club.
Yeah.
June 1st through third.
What's Denver mom?
Yeah,
Denver comedy works.
The downtown location.
And then June 16th or 17th man friend disco at the punchline comedy club.
I can't wait to see you guys there.
It's going to be fine.
Also checkout.
That's deep bro.
This week I talk about feeling like an imposter and then you'll have an
announcement to make.
Well,
but I not official save it.
Save it.
Oh,
and I should have paused to say that,
uh,
for 20 Bro,
Dallas,
Texas choice at the House of Bruise.
I added a show and then I go to Justin,
Texas the next few days.
All right.
Um,
this I thought you might like,
I don't know if you'd seen this or not,
but I had this bold for you.
Oh,
but you might enjoy,
what did you consider it?
A grown ass smile and to elevate and adult diaper having to clean it up.
What do you consider those hangers?
Low.
Awesome.
Big Ole sloppy.
She used to get those slap wagons under control.
Those are mushy purples.
Damn Bitch.
She's not wearing a bra.
We'll look up.
Pick.
Those are crazy.
Yeah.
That's got to hurt the back.
Right?
Sitting like that.
She's Chris.
I'm sitting in a chair.
Dude,
let us dumpers.
She needs to fucking harness those pigs
and I'm a feminist sex worker and an artist.
Sure.
As disco tits.
Those are hangers,
those milk.
Oh,
she's got a,
what's it called?
Piercings in those?
Yeah.
Did,
does flappers are nasty.
I can see that.
She's got,
she's got tattoos on a t two nasty girl.
Got that big old chess piece,
but discotheque man.
What do you think those way?
I'll tell you as somebody that's got big mushers,
I don't know.
I feel like they're five each.
At least it's got a nice face.
No,
she's,
she's beautiful.
She's fine.
Then just big ole hangars call sloppers yet,
dude,
I just can I tell you as somebody that has huge hangers not wearing a bra,
it's,
it's just so uncomfortable for me.
I can't imagine it being in a regular thing just got done working and she's
like,
oh yeah,
that's the best feeling.
When you get home from a long day,
you take your bra off,
it's the best.
Is there something equivalent for men?
I think pants off for men.
It's like a big thing.
You just walk around in your boxer.
I love walking around in my boxers.
He do it all the time in front of the nanny in front of everyone
I know.
Need to see your penis,
your lingo.
Power,
strong coconut oil massage.
I guess I'm my own pimp.
I meet most of my clients in line through websites that I have profiles on back
pages like craigslist,
but mostly like services with like sex work.
I have a Twitter and I get clients from that.
Funny enough to where,
yeah,
I think that's actually the safest place,
isn't it?
Because then you can kind of vet them a little bit and so there's this egg from,
yeah.
Yeah.
This egg.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Idealic London,
kind of like 150 from our supper.
Also,
I do discounts depending on my clients,
so if they're regulars and things of that kind of sex work,
I do ranges from Webcam to escorting,
making porn and domination services.
Maybe some ball kicking.
Punching.
[inaudible] your favorite jitterbugging.
Yeah.
Rad.
Femmes I swept a swath.
Is Sex work or sex work?
Exclusionary feminists.
Exclusionary.
Who?
Basically also Tufts.
Excuse me.
What for feminists would be like someone who's like anti-sex work cause
feminist.
Who's Anti-sex work?
It's a lot for failure basically.
That's,
that's why.
What's homophobia?
Oh,
homophobe.
Yeah,
right.
If you're,
if you're anti sex worker,
then you're,
you're homophobic.
Hey Guy,
can I agree?
Yeah.
You agree?
What if your anti-sex worker as a feminist,
I feel,
yeah.
Maybe it's a little homophobic.
Yeah.
I don't know what that means.
I'm pro sex worker.
That's why I'm always been pro sex work.
A lot of women don't have many options and yeah,
it's a pretty decent,
I mean,
especially if you're not getting beaten by a pimp,
you open your own shop.
Me Too man.
Rode beef
like a dot on the son of feminist who will say that like pro like women's
movements and their prior,
like women have an agency,
but then when it comes to sex with,
they completely against it.
When I'm fast,
actually sex work can give a lot of their agency.
It's better than being in like one wage job.
Right.
I don't know about that.
I mean
I've always chosen the minimum wage job.
Personally,
I just hate feminists.
Uh,
he was like this really old man.
He was like in his like 70s or 80s,
and he wants it like hardcore spanking and he was going into surgery the next
week
can,
he was like,
I might not come out of it alive,
so go for it.
Okay.
But he was super lovely.
I never saw him again,
so I don't know what happened.
Oh,
eat the Brits.
Love that spanking shit.
You know that there are hard and I really applaud an old guy going in for
surgery doing that.
Oh yeah.
You realize that guy was probably like this really might be my last hurrah.
Gimme a good old Spanish.
Yeah,
that's it.
Right.
There you go.
I was looking for the heat.
I don't see the clip for,
she asked him what's the,
they asked her.
What's the weirdest thing?
I definitely have had difficult.
I ships in the pot.
You Go.
I don't even date many of them.
Um,
I'm polyamorous and I only date queer people.
I don't even date men anymore,
so not dating men has made it a lot easier now.
A lot of my partners are also sex workers or have been sex workers while also
just generally open.
I'm polyamorous.
Yeah,
for sure.
Is the way to go only by,
okay.
They ask her what's the craziest request?
That's what I was looking at.
If somebody asked her to suck off their dog for 10 grand.
No,
there's no amount of money.
Oh she did?
Yeah,
she did.
No,
You wouldn't it off a dog for 10 grand.
Beastiality is off the table.
I boundaries bed.
Yeah,
but you're not hurting the dog.
He was kissing his penis.
No,
stop it.
They're innocence.
They're like children.
No,
you wouldn't suck off a child for $10,000.
Why would you let your Granddad jerk you off?
Yeah.
On the Ferris wheel.
Of course,
if it meant I'm not retarded.
Oh,
that was the best part that we forgot
in at at lunch with Dan Pena.
He said,
retard retards loud in a nice restaurant many times.
And it nearly caused me to lose my life because it was during bites and he'd be
like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm just kinda hauling these retards all over the goal line.
And I was like,
like I could not control myself.
What I liked Dan pain,
like,
I mean,
I've said it before is that just reminds me of almost everybody in my family.
He's just Hungarian.
Like that's an old school,
Hungarian person.
The way he taught us everything.
No nonsense.
Actually.
I would say even my Stepdad was like that too.
Just hardcore emigrant style dude.
It's old school.
That's all I,
that's all that is.
I like it.
Hard knocks,
kind of Shard cock.
Stefan knocks hard disks.
What?
So you had a really,
you had a really neat massage.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
I was all,
please talk about this.
I love this.
There's an app you can use to put this on your act because I think it's so
funny.
There's an APP.
I don't know if I want to,
should we tell him we say the APP doesn't matter.
Don't say the APP.
Don't give them a free fucking,
so there's an app they can pay like everyone else.
There's an app where you can be,
can be anywhere.
You can be a home,
you can be in a city.
I mean,
not everybody,
not every city obviously.
So it kind of like Uber and your hammock.
He'd be your hammock taking a dump.
Um,
Costa Rica,
but I don't know if they have them there yet.
But anyways,
so massage therapists side basically basically work anywhere can also join this.
And then they're on their,
basically they get a ping just like you would if you were an Uber driver.
Do you want to go take this appointment?
Like that?
So you put in your request,
I want 60 minutes,
90 minutes.
Uh,
this,
the time.
And this is the,
uh,
that's how the prostitution should be,
by the way.
I'm probably,
I'm sure it's going there.
Not they have an APP,
they should have an app or you can just be like,
I want a dom,
I want to change my diaper or want to be spanked.
Bang,
show up.
That's great.
I know that happening.
It's probably a whole legal issue.
But law,
the law is probably their problem.
Not In Nevada though,
right.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
I've had a long week,
I'm in the hotel and I go get a nice massage,
go to bed.
So I use the APP.
A person can they send you a confirmation?
Someone's coming at this time,
you know,
that's all it,
whatever.
Then the person texts you,
Oh,
you're at this hotel.
Yeah.
Cool.
Shows up.
It's like
Karen and Trish came to mind.
Both of them.
Yeah.
More often.
The one I kind of feel like it was,
yeah,
it was Chris.
Yeah.
Christian treren showed up at the same time.
Oh my.
Um,
you know,
a little beat down,
a little down on life.
Um,
one of the first things that I noticed,
uh,
which you don't always notice what you always get with a massage therapist was
the smallest strong smell of cigarette smoke usually that that profession brings
in more health conscious person.
But I was,
I was really flattered that prior to her coming up she had a nice cigarette.
I tell you.
Yeah.
Uh,
cause I've had it happen to at the Thai places.
Yeah,
they'll eat,
you know,
you can literally see them in the alleyway like push button out that cigarette
luminum and Kevin for you like dude,
you know,
and then the food service industry and massage industry doctors,
dentists,
if someone can smell your hands you probably shouldn't smoke immediately before
touching go also to not okay.
Massage table if your shoulders down but I'm was special with your face up.
That person's face is also right next to you.
So their breath,
a lot of times you pick up on their breath,
you know,
you get a whiff of it.
Yeah.
The best part about cigarette smokers,
cause I was a smoker for 17 years,
is that it just comes out of your pores.
It permeates,
it's out of every orifice is and comes out of your nostrils too.
Like you just,
you're a dragon,
you're just,
you smell like shit.
Smell terrible.
Yeah.
Affordable.
I loved smoking and I still did.
I do it.
I was a more social smoker,
but I really enjoyed it.
I love it.
It's a,
it's a fantastic habit.
Yeah.
Now it's,
it's horrifically bad for you,
but I enjoyed smoking for a long time,
but go ahead.
So,
so true.
So true.
She,
Karen Treren and Krisha Krisha um,
she's,
you know,
massaging and then I,
I heard
her go
and,
uh,
had like big throat clearing cough,
smoker's cough and then we go,
excuse me.
And I was like,
it's okay.
It was alarming.
It wasn't.
Okay.
What are you going to say?
And their phone go off or did she silence it?
Cause you've also had that,
it went off and uh,
she apologized.
Turn that off.
Um,
she was nice enough,
but she also was,
she tried,
she tried to start conversation rule number one.
No,
and I'm like,
and so she was like,
are you from?
And I was like,
Los Angeles.
Yeah.
You in town for work or,
yeah.
What do you do?
He said a consultant.
It's tech stuff.
Yeah.
You've got friends here know you got kids.
Where's this going and go?
Yeah.
You,
yeah,
mine are older.
Interesting.
Is that,
is that why you smoke?
Fucking,
they're all gone.
I just was like,
please stop.
She,
she picked up on that.
Um,
I hate it.
We can I give you a what?
I'll tell you what I do to PR to preempt any sort of conversation during a
massage.
Yeah.
What I do when they go,
any areas troubling you.
I tell them the areas and then I go,
oh,
but I'm just looking to fall asleep.
I'm probably going to pass out.
You warn them ahead.
I'm going to pass out here,
so don't fucking say anything.
And that helps a lot
when I was falling asleep.
See a lot of times you get,
if you get massaged regularly,
you'll know that sometimes when,
especially if you were face down,
they can't see your face,
so you thought the massage therapist will whisper to you in a very calm,
soothing,
almost halfway asleep voice.
They'll say you doing all right.
Okay.
So that you feel it Gentili right.
Question.
Yeah,
Tom,
it's time to turn it over now.
Take your time.
They got to take,
I'm in a,
I'm in that part where you're not quite asleep.
Definitely not fully awake and then I hear doing all right.
I was like,
oh my God.
I mean she said it so close to me and so loud that I almost shit my pants will
shit on her table.
I was like,
yeah.
She was like,
alright,
turn it over now.
Yeah.
And then did you get a whiff of her breath when she whispered to you?
Oh she got,
she got close to you and you smelled her cigarette breath.
Breath was hard.
That hands luckily because I was also like,
oh,
sometimes therapists start with their hands under the table so you can smell
them.
They'll have a Roma therapy on them.
And I was like,
Oh man,
her hands are going to stink.
But right away she has some lotion on them.
It was masking the cigarette smell.
They're definitely on a breath.
There was no,
there was no attempt to mask either,
which I also appreciate it.
There was no gum.
Yeah.
Again,
that,
that really is an occupation where generally your health,
kind of how,
what percentage of the time you think do you normally into a nonsmoker?
98%.
Yeah.
It's very rare.
The,
like I said,
the Asian ones,
sometimes in the alleyway they'll be smoking are there,
or the worst is when you go to the Thai place and they're cooking,
they're smelly food in the microwave and you can smell their food.
How their food stinks.
Yeah.
Smell.
You can smell them or you can hear them eating in the break room.
That's depressing.
But honestly,
I'll tell you
generally,
uh,
yeah,
you don't really run into those types.
Yeah.
Um,
so last week after I had a really good point to make about this,
about
not smoking,
the liberally I'll,
it'll come back to me.
We both been a while now with no cigarettes,
10 years for me,
10 years ago,
I'm at seven or eight crazy.
I started to smoke when I was 25 which is late in life.
It is,
yeah,
start early if you're really wanting to start to enjoy it more around shows
or before.
Is that the best time?
But I just a certain point,
I was like,
I gotta I gotta stop doing this.
You know,
I hit 30 and I was like,
I can't do this past 30.
I'm going to die.
Cause I started when I was 13 years old and,
and it was great for stand up to your right because the nerves that I used to
get,
like I would just chain smoke before and then after the release and also it
great.
So good smokes drinking and smoking together.
Coffee and smoking.
Fantastic stuff.
Everything.
Shit man,
I come on,
don't you know,
but I don't really miss it.
I used to miss it when I would smell it on other people and now it's not the
same.
I'm over it.
Um,
last week after the mom cast was done,
I think you all know,
we love the movies and we went to a movie that everyone's talking about it.
I've been dying to see it since I saw the trailer a couple months ago and that
is,
uh,
Jordan peals movie get out.
Um,
I really,
really enjoyed it.
So did I,
but I wish I would've been given a heads up.
Heads up.
You're like,
right,
let's go to the movies.
There's this thing I want to see.
And um,
I was like,
yeah,
great.
What is it?
You're like,
oh,
best if I don't tell you.
Is that like a romantic comedy?
Is it like a fun thing?
And you're like,
yeah,
it's fun.
And it's much like when I watch 12 years a slave and you told me that was a
comedy and then about halfway through it I wake you up and I'm like,
this is not funny.
This is not a funny movie.
Well,
there's a couple of things which is,
I guess we could start at the 12 years a slave.
I thought with the name of the movie and the press that the movie was getting.
No idea that that you might have known how not funny it was going to be.
I thought it'd be like a dark comedy.
Nope.
Maybe like Django.
There's,
there's moments where it was,
you know,
there's moments of formal Tarantino.
Yeah.
This is not that.
Anyways,
when you asked me and I was,
I remember I had just gotten back from overseas and so I was,
I was so jet lag.
I couldn't keep my eyes up and I was like,
you'll love it.
It's really funny.
And I passed out and then when you were like,
there's nothing funny in that.
I couldn't believe,
because this is the point in the movie where you asked me if the movie was heel.
You're like,
this is fucked up was in the beginning there's a murder.
One of the,
like it's the kills the guy and he throw them off the back of the ship and
you're like,
oh my God,
is this going to be like this?
And I go,
no,
it gets really funny.
Yeah.
You told me it was funny.
Yeah,
I know.
But I really didn't think that you bought in to the leafy,
when you say things I believe you realize so,
but this time I didn't come on.
This wasn't that level of no,
but I,
but I always like,
I always hate when people are a wrongfully accused.
Like those type of movies make me nuts.
And then I,
I hate when people are so victimized.
Yeah.
Like this movie I get so like,
like I get anxious and I feel so bad for them.
I hate it.
Yeah.
I just hate it.
We don't want to,
I definitely don't want to ruin this movie.
A good movie though.
Go see it.
It's really good.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the setup is that it,
you know,
I would say it deals with race and it deals with race relations in a really
clever story.
Um,
and there's so many small,
you know,
subliminal things and suggestions and metaphors throughout the movie.
Yeah.
It's what kind of movie that I know a lot of people are seeing it twice.
Okay.
Cause you do want to see it now.
I would like to see it a second time.
Yeah,
just took,
see the stuff that I didn't see the first time and it's Jordan Peele who,
you know,
a lot of people know from key and Peele wrote it and directed it and I did,
it was made for four and a half million dollars and over the weekend it crossed
the hundred million dollar.
Excellent.
Good.
Yeah.
Do it.
Go see it.
Help support and other comic and was the best part too is that we saw it with a
lot of black people in the audience,
which was way fun to too.
There's a lot of cheering.
There's a lot of motherfuckers screaming.
Yeah.
A lot of like damn boy.
Like so I was like homeboy and like it was really fun.
Laughs it's a theater experience.
Yeah.
This will,
this will be,
yeah.
Different if you rent it.
Yeah.
If you rent it on and when it gets to Itunes,
uh,
if you,
you know,
if you see a screen or something,
it will,
this is a fun movie theater experience.
Yeah.
So my,
my advice is that if you're considering going to the movies,
see that movie,
because it's going to be out of the theater soon.
You know,
like these movies don't,
it's already done a run.
If you,
if you think about it,
movies now are in theaters for like two weeks,
right?
So I would go see it,
try to go see it at a buck theater.
That's Sophie because it really does change the entire
do.
Do you remember the guy that was kept yelling,
homeboy?
Oh,
yours the funniest shit.
Or when when certain things happen to certain characters,
I don't want to give anything away,
man.
The cheers,
the screams.
It was,
it was really,
really,
really fun.
It was cool,
really cool.
People were really going crazy.
The only thing I've never done,
I've never seen him a dia movie in the theater and I thought,
Oh my God,
I love the Medea movies.
I love to see one of the,
I want to go to like a black theater though and see it.
I'm pretty cool.
Yeah,
that would be,
um,
that's something we can,
we can set that up.
Yeah.
Well this is for you because obviously you don't know how to do this Christ
and we've all done this.
Ended up picking out exit
easy cracker.
Yeah.
Finally being a genius new product that let you crack open eggs,
separate eggs,
even crack hard boiled egg.
I need an easy,
simply insert an egg into the grateful and squeeze instantly.
Crack.
Really Real.
This is real because it's a problem.
Did you see the examples?
Like every day you can crack on this.
I'm so stupid.
You right there on the counter.
No more messy.
Oh God.
I gotta just keep rubbing it in.
Separates any size ag
where you're fussing over,
mom,
will you make more A's?
Eggs?
All right.
Oh,
can I get in the cradle and oh,
and it catches the yolk.
Wow.
If it works that way,
I mean,
what would make you think that?
It doesn't work that way.
It never works.
I guarantee it
shows everything.
Fucking shell.
Susie cracker,
he reminds me of a new show.
I got you.
Uh,
why don't you make a new album and call it easy cracker.
You should do that fucking crack.
Oh my God.
He called me that.
I just got you into the great British baking show.
I've seen bits and pieces of one of the earlier seasons you were watching and it
got enough.
I got enough interested where I do it,
dude.
Season two,
like I like cooking.
I like baking because it's so hard and it's so scientific and there's a really
perverse satisfaction that I get from watching them make it,
showing it,
wanting to eat it,
and then not eating well.
You know what,
it's like pornography or something.
You know what I do?
I like to put,
we have fragrance maker.
What is that called in the room?
Jane the diffuser and I put in sugar cookie oil and vanilla oil and I diffuse
that smell in the room and I light candles and that way I feel like I'm,
I'm being a bad girl without actually eating the treats.
I feel like I had a dessert when I,
yeah,
you know,
that's why I watch it.
We were off,
the carbs were off the sugar,
but I can watch someone else bake it and I liked that part,
you know,
and some of them make also there's an artistic element are beautiful and and all
those British teeth and it's just all so nice.
Season Two's teeth were horrific and we just started season three and those
teeth are way better.
But season two wolf talk about the dog pound in those teeth really bad.
And that's the stereotype with,
you know,
British people,
and I hate to say it,
but season two really fulfilled that stereotype.
Really exciting dental update guys.
Now in a,
and as I Rooney and fate would have it,
this segment started Tom when I had a root canal a few years ago and had to put
a crown on this bottom back molar back door.
And that's when this started.
Dental updates,
full circle.
I'm having this crown replaced again because it was done in correctly the first
time and it didn't line up with the rest of my team.
So I have a temp in there.
Yeah,
you see it?
It's like the wrong color.
It's all white.
Like really,
really white.
Yeah.
And I'm Steve Harvey's going jazz's billboard's going and the lady told me,
the dentist told me,
he goes,
now you don't want to chew anything hard or sticky cause it'll tear it out.
And if that happens on a weekend,
don't call me cause I don't want to open the office to just put a temp back in
while you can do is go down in the store and get some denture cream and just
glue it back in until Monday.
And I was like,
well that's a really neat thing to say.
Thank you doctor.
Yeah,
we don't really do that for you.
That's what that means.
Harvey,
Steve or a friend,
Garth.
Uh,
but luckily,
knock on wood,
I haven't ripped it out yet.
The thing is,
every time I've ever had attempt to thin,
I've had temp teeth and a few times they always fucking fallout.
Always.
But you know what he told me,
which was interesting is that because I've had this tooth root canal,
he's like,
if the crown falls off,
it doesn't matter.
It can't rot.
Like you can't get bacteria and it's already dead.
I'm like,
that's neat.
That's kind of an interesting story.
Now the struggle for me has been though I can't floss around the temp.
Yeah,
and I've been eating bitsy does like that.
Yeah.
I ate some meat the other day.
I got wedged in there,
Bacon this morning.
It's all wedged in there and I can't do a fucking thing about it.
Just wait till they take it out.
It's going to stink really bad.
And I've been flossing all the other teeth,
but it's a Massey damn.
Well,
you got to be some niche.
Here's the good news.
Now listen,
here's a second part to my update.
So I found out that my veneers actually can't be stained.
So this whole time I've been worried about that standing my veneers,
but my natural teeth can be stained,
so I'm going to Whiten my teeth to match my veneers because it's been a couple
of years since I've whitened.
And then when are you going to do that though?
I'm going to do that the day I get my new crown.
Next week I'm going to do bang,
Bang.
Crown takes 15 minutes and then I'm going to have him whitening in the office.
And you're going to be super jealous when you see how beautiful my teeth.
I don't know.
I think I'm most thinking I might have you actually do my whitening trays
tonight,
which he never did.
You always say tonight we see that the great British baking show.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we took Ellis to the dentist for the first time too,
and he had a dental chair.
He had flying colors because mom's been brushing his teeth already.
Yeah.
He really loved having his teeth checked.
Two hated that fucking terrible.
It was horrifying.
Anyway,
you've been having trouble.
Yeah.
What happened?
What's going on with you been,
I'm not trying to show off but I've been doing so well.
No,
you are showing on.
I don't know.
It's just so easy.
You've been bragging about your browns all day today.
Yeah.
And you had,
I mean you made changes yesterday cause you had trouble yesterday and then you
said,
ah,
I'm going to have some,
what's some fruit?
Okay,
so yesterday when it happened I had some ones,
I made a number of their kibbles and then I thought of I have some mango that
usually pushes down the brown.
It didn't work.
That's usually a goto.
So today I made coffee to start the day.
Of course I did not think it pushed out a few kibbles and then I made,
yeah,
you made poop soup and you had two bolts by the third ball.
We're going to start to see some action,
mango
and more coffee.
And when I got back in here
[inaudible]
you know what the problem is?
Saturday I broke the Diet.
I had a ton of sugar,
I had wine,
I had pasta and cheese.
So my body is fucked.
I got to get back on fiber.
It's all about the fiber intake.
Now.
Last night we were laying in bed and you go,
what do you think?
Do you think I'm going to Fart or do I have to shit?
And I said,
judging by your,
it's your travel day.
And usually when you announce it like this,
when you,
when you question it,
that means a shit's coming.
We're breaking it down for me.
I started to laugh and the laughing prompted me to go,
isn't that I got to go?
Yeah.
And then you had a shit today when you got home
this morning.
Yeah.
Why has God blessing you so much?
God blesses you.
Why don't you rub offs into that chocolate on me?
No,
no,
no.
Just the way it goes.
The way it goes.
Pretty lucky guy.
Yeah.
Thanks.
I feel bad for you.
Actually.
I do too.
I hate being cost.
I hate number ones.
I hate type.
It's not even a shit.
Oh,
we should talk about it.
The Facebook page.
Oh my God.
Dirty and disgusting.
Um,
so you guys know that we have a Facebook page and we post some stuff there.
We've been doing actually Facebook live videos after the podcast is done
recording.
So like when we're done with this right now,
we'll post a video live from here.
Um,
hopefully I'll be browning.
Yeah.
So that's something that we started doing at anyways.
There's that.
Some fans that listen to the show started a live or a Facebook group,
it's called,
um,
you have to,
yeah,
Facebook groups.
There's,
there's your mom's house podcast page.
That's us.
And then you're at your mom's house podcast group.
So search under groups on to go to the green tab on Facebook and put in your
mom's house.
And as some of the funniest shit,
man,
they tastic they are killing it.
I mean,
as people are posting stuff all the time and the comments are fucking
hysterical.
Um,
there's some people really like the Jimmy Dean sausage bit so much.
There's a lot of people posting that people are like,
I took a brown today.
Like just post.
Yeah.
Uh,
Oh,
here's the present time.
This was really,
this made me laugh really hard.
This is,
uh,
somebody posted this.
Hi,
Mommy's mushy per mercy purple Patty here.
I just wanted to say that I saw my mommy last night.
Tommy buns in boss.
Come at [inaudible].
We drove two hours to see the champ and we're not disappointed.
I was pleased to see that he finally took Christina's advice to perform his
jokes as a mentally challenged person.
His performance put to shame Tom Hanks in Forrest Gump.
Sean Penn and I am retarded.
The man can do anything.
Yeah.
It was overwhelming to be in the presence of greatness.
He was perfection in human form.
Tom was so good at one point.
I forgot that he wasn't retarded.
Game Changer.
He's paving the road for a future comedians.
I wouldn't be surprised if you saw other people trying to copy his act,
but just don't have the stand [inaudible] to pull it off.
Hopefully we can.
He,
he can.
He just keeps pushing and training.
You know what I'm saying?
Tom Cigarette is retard champ.
Wow.
Um,
there's a lot of posts like that.
Just funny shit,
man.
Photoshop.
Yeah.
They're all
videos.
They found,
the thing that I love about this is that I've been wanting this since day one is
a place for mommies to go and meet each other and make new friends.
Yeah.
I wish we could do a dating site.
That's just people who love our show and then they can meet other,
you know,
I feel like guys,
gals,
non binaries who are just came out with this here.
There's,
there's like 3,500 people.
Yeah.
Already there.
It just start in it or that grew over the weekend.
Yeah.
And they're doing like dad posts,
Brown posts.
Um,
one person wrote this,
my favorite,
he's like,
I figured it out.
This is just your mom's house is a place for immature adults there.
Right.
And it's totally true.
Yeah.
It's totally true.
That's true.
No,
I'm a member of the group,
but I did you join?
Yeah.
Did they accept your membership?
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
Because I was debating whether or not to join cause I'm like,
oh,
is this going to be weird for people?
Will they be like,
this is like your parents,
you're looking at your Facebook page.
Oh right.
No,
I'm saying yes or no claim but I don't think so.
I don't think it was happening.
Um,
pretty funny though.
It's,
it makes me laugh a lot.
Funny stuff.
Why am person I posted something recently.
They were like,
hey guys,
real talk.
Does it bother you ever?
Would they talk about brown talk and everybody is like,
no,
the only thing better than brown talk is burping or whatever.
Got to use some guy wrote in like,
what's going on with this group?
I thought this was something else.
Like what's this all guy?
Yet he got lit up with 300 plus comments.
I mean I love it,
but I really funny stuff.
Like people were like,
your genes are low and loose.
You didn't get your life.
You don't have any common your balls.
Like nobody actually answered.
They just used all jokes.
Uh,
it's so funny because somebody was like,
I have to quit my job because it's getting in the way of enjoying this Facebook
group.
It's true.
I'm on there and I keep looking at it.
So funny dude.
Okay.
Oh,
for a long time.
A long time.
People always asked us to do some besides
my brown.
Oh good.
So we finally did a Hoodie.
This is a,
it's super,
super soft hoodie.
Like you know there's that material.
It's very soft kind of lighter hoodie.
It's a lighter,
like a spring Hoodie.
Yeah.
So when you're kind of in between the seasons,
maybe this is a good,
it's not like a super heavy one or a summer eve.
Really great material.
And it says Jean Singular,
singular because that's our new name.
Jean Jean in denim lettering,
but very well done.
It's on the,
it's in the store.
So I was always for your support.
I think you'll,
you'll very much enjoy it,
Jean,
for those of you don't know this,
the references at first,
we call each other genes.
Mommy genes,
genes.
And then we had a worker in our home.
Was it the carpenter?
The old man who shit in my house,
electrician,
electrician.
He came here and he,
within five minutes of meeting me,
took a dump in our bathroom.
Yes.
But he heard Tom calling me genes.
And so when we answered the door and the Entercom,
he goes,
Hey Jean,
it's me.
And I was like,
did he just call me Jean?
And it happened.
And now is gene gene [inaudible] gene.
And when you went to Canada,
I called the John St James.
Y'All Belge when you're in Canada.
I'm very excited.
We're very excited about the Hoodie.
Check it out when you get a chance.
All right.
Um,
Saint Jean,
this came in.
I haven't heard it,
but I'm already excited.
Myla Kunis Mila,
she's my tribe.
She's not Hungarian,
but she's like,
she's Rooskie playing.
Yeah.
Um,
apparently she has some really profound vocal fry shut up
inside the rack houses of Jim beam.
Thousands of barrels lay silent [inaudible] inside each and every Jim beam
barrel.
The Bourbon is building a fuller,
smoother flavor.
Only comes from being aged four long years.
Made from the inside.
Uh,
yeah.
I'm guessing that she's trying to sound more sultry.
Social.
She's going lower and maybe that's why it's coming out.
She speaks Russian.
She does speak Russian and she's a smart broad.
That doesn't mean
she's married to Ashton Kutcher could Cushner yeah.
Future flavor flavor there for long years.
Cars.
Yeah.
Oh,
oh Ma Dragon.
Those octaves out.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
yeah,
it's pretty good there.
It's always there.
You know about this?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
She's going to teach you out.
No thanks.
Wow.
But how do you get it?
I mean,
how do you get the air in?
Cause I don't just queef when I lay on my back,
it doesn't just come out.
Well,
how would you teach someone to do it?
I don't know how to do it on command.
I don't know how.
I mean I,
it's,
it's only accidentally that that's happened accidentally.
I got it.
Right,
right.
That's good instruction far
sandwiches.
The funny farm
I've had.
No,
I'll give you a few samples goes great.
Okay.
She's great.
Do you think,
what do you think her friend situations,
like what do you think are dating situations?
Like what do you think are parenting situations like go?
I think her friends say she's the best and loyal friend.
Good girl.
Yeah.
Uh,
a lot of guys feel like she is a two groups and uh,
she doesn't have a lot of longterm relationships.
No.
Well look,
it's one thing to know it's her dad.
What else?
Well it's one thing to do this in front of your buddies like drunk.
Yeah.
It's another thing to actively make a video and put it online.
That's a really bold choice.
Yeah.
I mean
of your fanny packs.
Fanny Fart.
Fanny's your cooch.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
we have a sloppy what?
Sloppy one.
Yeah,
She Australian or English.
She's awesome.
Yeah,
she's doing the um,
she's using the same principles of changing the pitch of your bug farts with her
fanny farts.
Oh that's an interesting idea.
Yeah.
She's telling you if you move your legs like this and remember last night when
we were getting the snack.
Yeah.
God Damn Snag.
You were walking towards me in the kitchen and you were mad.
You birthed and then you lifted your leg up and you farted.
Yeah.
That was really special.
I was really disappointed that I,
I couldn't get them in sequence.
All right.
Cause you go,
you go,
cause you went,
you went.
It's not,
it's not a double pipe.
It's not a double pipe.
Yeah,
you're were like,
it was seconds away.
It's not like you can't half a second one.
Yeah.
You were in phatic that it wasn't and you know,
I wasn't even thinking that.
I was just like,
look at the choreography on that.
That it,
a leg lifts you birthed.
I was blown away by your moves.
Thank you.
Very turned on.
I could tell.
Yeah.
Ooh.
All right.
So,
oh right.
I keep forgetting that to her vagina.
Oh,
you forget.
I just forgot it.
Can't stop thinking about it.
I just forgot about it.
But you forget.
I don't know.
I just,
for a moment I got distracted by the story of Migrate Fart.
Yeah.
I'll just try it some more.
Ooh,
no,
and just for license,
all your Pi,
your angriness site,
your stress,
it just helps you guys get the Aa rare.
I think it smells.
No,
not at all.
Her Vagina or just in general?
General briefing.
I don't think so.
It should.
It depends if your he smells right.
If you're,
if you're,
if you have a strong odor down there,
then the wind coming out of it probably.
Right.
I mean,
you know,
if he ever keep it clean you shouldn't.
Yeah.
And that was really nice.
Thank you lady.
Yeah,
that was kind of a,
yeah,
exactly.
You know,
I'm glad we can't make out her face too much for her benefit.
Would you date the Queef girl?
Be Honest.
You know,
let's say like I'm the Queen of girl.
What if I made that video when I was 20 years old and everybody in the club was
like,
listen,
Tom,
did you,
have you seen Christina is queen video?
I know you guys are dating.
Oh yeah,
I dunno.
I would definitely rate her.
No,
it wouldn't be a deal breaker.
I mean,
you're a comic and I,
I would,
I would probably find it funny.
Yeah,
no,
I would still go out with you.
What'd you demand that I do?
The queef I'm sure it would come up.
I'm sure it would come up.
I don't think that you could have that out there and me be like,
oh,
just overlook that.
Completely know how would ask about it.
Yeah.
Do you want me to learn how to do that?
I think it would add a little spark,
some fun
if two wheels are locked on an axle so that they are not free to turn
separately.
One or the other.
As to slide,
he boy engineers had to find a way to connect both rear wheels to the engine
without sliding and slipping on turns.
The device which makes this possible board now is a part of the rear axle now on
the differential looks complicated,
but once we understand its principle,
it is amazingly simple.
These two wheels are molded on separate.
You're done and I should find that interesting.
My Dad was a mechanic of course yet,
but I just don't care.
I don't care.
Yeah.
I kind of want to know how cars work,
but not really.
You want to see a dad owner before we could ask?
Yeah.
I Love Dad boners.
This is a dad boner.
I think he's feeding birds.
Let me see if this says anything here.
Dad voter.
It goes to the park feed birds.
Oh,
he's stuck by how many there are.
I love it.
I don't know.
But that's a month.
The damn birds,
after I'm at Mudd,
they all over the damn place.
I got me a little sack of,
and he had seen my brain.
I'm always thinking,
man,
I've been asked Steve and some of them marriage,
see me.
Oh yeah,
I bet.
Today Leah.
Whoa.
Something tells me he's not from Boston.
Jesus.
Oh,
look at that
with all my food and have a look out.
Oh look,
I'm good Lord.
That's a numbers girl,
Mami and all my brand.
It's hilarious.
He's really exciting.
Oh,
look at me screaming at me and
look at them off coming in.
I don't know.
What the hell am I looking at the time?
I don't know if I concentrate him as a dad.
Boehner necessarily.
No,
I'm excited.
I'm about,
I'm about as excited as he is,
right?
Yeah.
Hmm.
I mean,
he's definitely excited,
but he doesn't,
he doesn't have that dad vibe necessarily now.
No,
it's there.
Yeah.
He's a gay black dad boner.
Oh,
that's so a Walmart got Walmart apples and then we got,
yeah,
it's dangerous.
Don't get here by now.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I like we'd birds like that.
Yeah,
I get excited over that.
Okay,
girl.
Yeah.
They come in all the hair.
Um,
gene for our closing songs.
Somebody did a freestyle over the,
fill her up.
Oh,
let me see how
up and comer reached out to Ali's Eser.
Oh,
okay.
I'll,
he makes a lot of great songs.
Yes.
So the up and comer got the beat to fill her up from Ali's Eser and rapped over
it.
Very cool.
That's what this is.
Mary,
go to fill her up.
Why am I looking?
I'm like looking at,
I'm waiting for the video.
Yeah.
Dummy Ramsay McQueen.
Oh,
okay.
Ramsey.
Um,
as always,
thank you for listening.
Go to your mom's house,
podcast.com Tom,
cigarette.com for tickets to shows.
Uh,
also the store is there.
If you want the gene hoodie and thousand ranch.com for gene,
uh,
to get tickets to her show.
Um,
I think that's it.
Gene.
That's it,
mommy.
All right,
bye guys.
Greg,
my boss always just drawn.
You bought me and my boy crazy notes went down.
It's Barbara.
Gosh,
no,
I don't want to sound pushy.
Come here girl.
Let me tell you.
Oh yeah,
you could be my car.
It could be a hobby lobby.
Then go throw you off.
So what your shot?
Nope,
pay plan.
I don't have to Samsung.
Just understand.
All I want to do is
wow.
Yeah.
The time.
Brian Jean Paul.
Hi.
What was pretty sure I could get up cause she talking to by the end of the
night.
It was super excited.
Both.
Fuck.
I can still pull crews.
Lord knows I ain't need that phone.
I was like,
Hey,
hit La.
Was like,
Yo,
what's up?
[inaudible] I was like,
let's just saying it could be my misses.
We can go now or we can do cool stuff.
Stuff,
stuff,
stuff.
Alright.
When shall we be you sitting up on the fourth floor?
Wow.
She looks so dumb.
She was coming.
The roles.
Yeah Babe.
It's about time.
She said if you want,
here's the deal.
This procedure,
it's like a succulent Chinese meal.
Oh,
okay babe.
I ain't going to Bob.
I'm going to streamline.
Bye.
I just want to match bubbles just the the day who's truly amazed at double pipe
class shit cut soon as I came.
Okay.